Aurore berger la patronne de des députés
Renaissance à l'Assemblée nationale
recommande à ses collègues de ne pas
disputer un match de football caritatif
programmé ce soir à 18h au motif que des
députés du rassemblement national seront
sur le terrain sans doute ont-ils le
choléra ou la peste maladie hautement
contagieuse moins cependant que la
bêtise qui a contaminé madame berger
mais aussi les parties de gauche ce
qu'on nomme les forces de progrès et qui
progressent effectivement chaque jour
dans la critinerie pour le coq capitaine
de l'équipe des parlementaires cette
décision est une instrumentalisation
politique qui n'a pas lieu d'être lors
d'un événement caritatif voilà comment
on prend en otage en otage une équipe
qui vient pour la bonne cause où on
pourrait apporter une image autrement
plus je dirais louable que celle parfois
qu'on renvoie et j'en suis au sein de
l'assemblée
en réalité c'est la haine tout le temps
partout il y a pas un espace où ils
peuvent admettre que et bien nous sommes
des députés on joue contre d'ailleurs
des équipes étrangères qui vont nous
regarder comme des en nous prenant pour
des pignons fin je pense qu'ils seront
jugés assez durement par les Français
des sportifs des politiques des actrices
et même des médecins futurs stars de
lecture le président de l'Université de
la Méditerranée bonjour il est important
que ceux qui font des conférences dans
le monde entier face aussi quelques
conférences à Marseille madame berger
qui est dans la posture dans l'espace
médiatique elle s'achète une sorte de
virginité pour dire à l'espace
médiatique elle sera mieux traitée dans
Libération elle sera mieux traitée sur
France Inter
sur sur le service public elle elle sera
mieux traitée sur le service public
quand tout est politique se rencontrent
c'est sympa parce que ça permet de au
députés de montrer que derrière le
costume il y a un cœur du Maurice qui
bat
on a un peu triché on a on a récupéré
Nicolas douchesse qui était un ancien
footballeur
et donc on va essayer de limiter
l'addition on va essayer d'éviter que ça
fasse 49-3 à la fin du match
vous l'avez bah oui ce qui est flagrant
c'est qu'en 25 ans ça n'a pas beaucoup
changé
de près l'apparition d'un tout nouveau
virus proche du covid du virus Costa 2
identifiez chez les chauves-souris Costa
2 pourrait se transmettre à l'homme et
un quai donc de plus en plus
effectivement c'est pas très rassurant
on parle même d'une menace mondiale
encore ce nouveau virus pourrait même
échapper au vaccin actuel des vaccins
qui existent aujourd'hui contre le covid
y compris que trop Mikron ne sont pas
efficaces bon de panique à la terrasse
d'un restaurant au Brésil sur les images
de vidéosurveillance de l'établissement
on voit quelques personnes courir sur le
trottoir puis tous les clients se lèvent
qui se mettent à fuir aucun danger n'est
pourtant à signaler c'est un groupe de
jogger qui a semé le doute le restaurant
indique qu'une fois leur esprit retrouvé
les clients ont rejoint leur table un
nouveau Spider-Man débarque et sa
promesse
ce matin bambou
je connais pas les deux
on va tenter ce matin d'Axelle Red mais
sans grande conviction moi c'est tous
les matins
le CIF c'est l'acronyme de sillon
inter-fessiers c'est la reine des fesses
en fait c'est la réduction frontale
[Musique]
très bien bonne pirouette mais c'est pas
le même endroit ça se saurait pas de
points sur cette question
Eric je dirais bien que j'avais un peu
la tête dans le
à la perceuse de retour la perceuse la
fameuse perceuse ah
la personne est de retour
la perceuse est de retour otage mais non
pas sabotage c'est à dire que je le dis
alors je le dis à chaque fois mais nous
avons changé de
nous avons changé
de siège
donc nous avons des installations
somptueuses désormais tout le siège
canal mais c'est vrai qu'il y a encore
quelques travaux sur TF1 le boss du 20H
c'est PPDA le 18 mars il reçoit Sharon
Stone et commence l'interview comme ça
Sharon Stone bonsoir est-ce que vous
aimez le calamars d'abord à manger si je
veux vous inviter ce soir à dîner par
exemple il faut que j'évite les
restaurants de poissons le C animal
marin qui forme une grande barrière au
large de l'Australie
cachalot non c'est le corail
comme un beauf qu'ils ont bien raison et
qui continuent je suis un beau c'est à
dire je suis un garçon cultivé qui aime
les autres qui ne boit pas d'alcool qui
ne se drogue pas qui ne prend pas de
tranquillisant qui a pas de psy qui fait
tout pour rendre les gens autour de lui
heureux qui organise la fête qui prend
ses responsabilités qui est toujours là
quand un copain va mal si c'est ça un
beauf moi je vous souhaite à tous d'être
des beaux comme moi fait beaucoup de
temps
on parle souvent de l'âge des actrices
et je me demandais pour les acteurs ça
change quoi d'avoir 50 ans c'est parfait
c'est génial je dis 50 ans ça claque 51
c'est nul 51 c'est pourri et là on en
est où là 58 ça va c'est à 5 ans je suis
très bien